how do you confront someone with a hard
truth today I want to give you five tips
for how to do that really well my name's
Brett silver pastor at the table and
sexy Texas and it's a privilege to
welcome you to Table Talk where I bring
you ideas and insights from Christian
theology and spirituality that help you
become a more thoughtful calm and
wonderful human being
all right so let's get to our five steps
for successfully navigating conflict and
confront someone with a hard truth step
number one you got to own your part so
this might seem like a really strange
place to begin because we're talking
about how to confront others and yeah
it's so easy to go into a confrontation
with this idea that that you are the
angel and they are the demon the reality
is that most of the time there is almost
always something you can own right this
is especially true if this was like a
mutual fight or you were both in a
heated argument with you know raging
emotions and hurtful words spoken by
both parties I mean if that's the
situation you can always go into that
follow up conversation yes like ready to
address their stuff but first be ready
to address your own right so start the
conversation by owning your part of
course in situations where there has
been physical abuse sexual abuse or when
someone was just super out of line
that's different right but those really
are the exceptions rather than the rule
so that's step one on your part step two
be clear be kind
so Ephesians chapter four verse 15 says
speaking the truth in love we will grow
to be
in every respect the mature body of him
who is the head that is Christ and it's
the first line that jumps out at me
speaking the truth in love that's the
trick isn't it like on the one hand in
the name of loving someone we're so
often not straightforward with them
we're like we're not honest we're sort
of dancing around you know the topic
we're sort of unclear because we don't
want to hurt their feelings so much or
at least that's what we say on the other
hand we can also find ourselves speaking
the truth without love right I mean
we're a straight shooter but we just
come across like a jerk and our words
are rarely if ever really received so
what we've got to do is is have both
love and truth kiss each other in our
confrontations so that second be clear
be kind third Ask Don't Tell I got this
from my good friend windy good
oftentimes we go into a confrontation
with a lot of assumptions we assume we
know where they were coming from when
they said that thing that hurt our
feelings we just know why they did what
they did and now we are full of
righteous indignation let me tell you
this will this will kill you this will
humiliate in humble you learn from my
failures friends never assume anything
in the conflict and so in other words
instead of saying well you said this and
and I know why you said that is because
you were thinking you know fill in the
blank or so last week when you yelled at
me my name knew I knew it was because
ask but when you said such and such what
did you mean what when you did such and
such what why did you do that now you're
going to feel ridiculous because you are
oh so sure that you already know don't
assume I'm telling you I swear to you
don't
as soon as don't tell and by the way
when they give you a reason believe them
unless you have like very clear evidence
that they're lying but if you're just
speculating if you're just like I just
don't think stop it just believe them
and like think about it in the case that
they're really lying it will probably
come out later right so that's step
three alright step 4 use eye language
not you language so I found this is
helpful because it really encourages us
with all the points that I just
mentioned above like it basically helps
us be kinder it helps us ask more
questions because really we have to
frame it in a much less accusatory
manner than we normally would so for
example what we might say hey last week
when we got into that screaming match I
really had my feelings hurt I felt like
I didn't even matter to you and perhaps
that's not true but it's just how it
felt so notice how different that is as
opposed to last week we on that
screaming match you were the biggest
joke in the world you were out of line
you are the worst and by the way this is
not some weird rule where you can like
literally never say you in a
confrontation that just gets weird it's
simply a helpful sort of framework of
model to to reframe the Congress
in terms of your own perspective your
own feelings and invites other people to
own their part right rather than you
having to force it upon them step number
five get a mediator
when in doubt bring someone else in what
whether it's because you're just new to
all this or you just don't really trust
the person or the situation just feels
so delicate but you or the other person
just flat-out needs some help don't
hesitate to reach out and of course the
person you asked to be this third party
they they need to be spiritually and
emotionally mature that they need to be
someone neutral in the conflict someone
as unbiased as possible they need to be
also an agreed upon third party not just
you saying I want this person but you
know someone agreed upon and finally
they have to be really strong and
willing to call you and the other person
out on your jacked up this here menace
toughness your issues I said it can't be
a mousy peacekeeper you know they need
to be relatively comfortable in this
type of situation pretty confident
person right so that's the five tips on
your part be clear be kind Ask Don't
Tell use eye language not you language
get a mediator so I hope you find these
tips really useful wherever you find
yourself at home at work at church
wherever you are in the journey and that
it encourages you to confront people
with more confidence but also with
kindness so that is all for today if you
enjoyed this video please go ahead and
comment below and if you don't want to
miss any future episodes of Table Talk
be sure to subscribe to my youtube
channel by searching for Brett Tilford
on YouTube love y'all laughs grace in
peace